be doing this trying to get their
attention just chill like the man will
come to you but you're just trying to go
near them because you're dying for the
attention men don't find that attractive
they don't smart man doing fine I feel
like we're smart I feel like we're
beating the dead horse at this point
yeah yeah I just want to know like what
your routine of self-worship is like do
you do you look at yourself in the
mirror
[Music]
Every Woman here
in here more or less not you probably
wait wait wait wait wait wait how is
how is understanding how the other
species operates and how what they value
what they want how is understanding them
a pick me when we always say well wait
wait wait wait when we always say that
they need to understand women they need
to understand women it's like how are
you supposed to be in a relationship
with someone you when you get in a
relationship with friends you try to
understand your friends who and you want
them to understand you so you can grow
that relationship so you could be the
best friend they have in that
relationship how are you going to be
one-sided and say oh we don't need to
understand man we don't need to know
this about men they need to understand
Us and how we operate and that's a pick
me if we try to understand how they
operate to be able to have a good
relationship to not be single at 40 with
12 kids to not die alone with a dog how
is that a pick me well [ __ ] said
because you think that that
understanding or their like are they not
human no no course they're human but you
think that it is like
it's truth it's gospel it's like
determining the fact like I I cannot
accept that uh you think that's what's
true
what's true like what's gospel you you
saying that oh um certain women don't
deserve certain things like because
that's their perspective and their
understanding
we all must now accept that as it's a
choice it's choices have consequences
and if you and if you choose and if you
choose to make certain decisions the
consequences that most men will not want
to court you and the ones that do you
will not like
so do you you believe that every single
woman should be courted I do why you
think they're entitled to that yeah so
then do you believe because we were
talking about equal exchanges right so
if you believe all women deserve to be
courted
why do men not why are men not entitled
to six at the end of it
at the end of being courted oh yeah
sex is a person's life
sex the point of sex is actually to
bring life into the world okay but it's
been reduced the value of sex is far
more than
stop over talking me you've done it so
many times the show you need to stop
doing it women in the 1950s deserve to
be courted because they were virgins why
on Earth would a man Court a girl that's
not a virgin nowadays when you've given
it to other men for free why like I said
at the beginning if the point of it is
to have good sex someone who's already
had sex is probably going to give you
better sex than a virgin
yeah yeah that makes sense
you see where you said there like wait
wait but then wouldn't he want it now no
no no
Stephen why would he Court her wouldn't
he date her mother
why would he wait for that okay and then
I will say but he could go down the
street and talk to Rebecca Who's down
now and then I will say there's also 25
years old without 12 kids yeah go down
the street and talk to Rebecca and have
and have sex with her straight away and
whatnot and then decide what it is that
you're looking for are you actually
looking for someone who's gonna raise
your home and raise your children and
look after your home properly and if you
are then you should take time to look at
that person look at their values
understand them properly and spend time
and money on them without sex
sorry okay what is eliminating sex
I think I think one uh sex does like um
it it fogs judgment for a woman not man
I think you know me as a woman yeah so
I'm talking from a woman's perspective
because but I'm asking you I'm asking
you from their point of view I don't
know men's point of view
but you're saying you don't care though
from Men's point of view why on Earth
would they Court you if you're not a
virgin why would they wait for sex when
it's not even guaranteed at the end
spend money when it's not nothing is
guaranteed to them exactly because
you're saying you're saying that your
saying that [ __ ] has the most value the
fact that I matter is a man is spending
his time energy and resources that he
has to attain to get the [ __ ] why is
the [ __ ] any more valuable let me make
a point based on what I said earlier you
said for example that all were meant to
record great I said to you earlier if a
woman is devaluing herself and
disrespecting yourself and I'm sure you
know girls I know girls that just are
out there and they're married yes
so
as I was saying so those women that are
disrespectful
to themselves and just throwing
themselves out there like I said a man
can tell a wife material you can tell
you can take on one first day doesn't
mean you have to quote her and take her
out take her out take her out what are
you doing with her you should know from
that first initial reaction I should
know all right cool what's this person
about do I actually like this person
spend your time asking the the right
questions if that's what your goal is
only men that actually want a woman
they'll ask the right questions if they
just want to have sex with you they're
just going to take you and have sex if a
man is not going to stay right yeah but
most women do that nowadays you're
saying you don't but we all know women
out there that just give it out and
that's the point so most women don't
deserve Gordon simple as unless if a man
Spends His resources his time and energy
on you over time you owe him six at the
end of that no you absolutely owe him
six you're paying a value on sex and it
does not you're the one who just said it
was the most valuable
you're contradiction no no it's price if
you if it's a price you can't if it's a
face I truly believe you don't know
where the [ __ ] you are right now what do
you mean I believe you don't know where
you are I believe you've dug a hole so
deep you can't get out you're trying to
fight you're trying to scratch yourself
to go deeper and deeper I don't think
you know where you are super super chat
really quick I read I read this okay
um James Ryan do you only keep these
people on the show for Content all her
ticks show that she is not going to
listen and will never listen because she
already has an established position it's
a social media trap and you have to be
what your audience wants okay that's it
can I can I ask a question is there any
older women who have the same mindset as
you none that you know
there isn't no so you know you said a
lot of your whole friends are married
right are there any women who may be
more like you are they married as well
or what results are they getting
yeah actually I have some friends like
me that I'm married I'm married as well
okay lucky I was just a bridesmaid at
one wedding okay so
um
Alex has a presentation for us
well
I mean come on Alex I think this should
work really well on you actually
no no
you go grab it go grab the Whiteboard so
Alex made up
yeah um so before the show
um Alex was here and he came up with a
presentation on how he dates modern
women
oh here we go yeah yeah so we we got a
whiteboard God thank you for the
donations to get us a whiteboard
also we also bought blessing a chair
it hasn't come in yet though so it's
okay all right so if you get yeah yeah
so if you could if you could zoom in as
many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible